[Music]
hello and welcome to conan o'brien needs
a friend podcast a journey if you will
three friends making their way through
the audio world forging relationships
of course matt gourley joining me hello
matt hi it's great to be here with my
two best friends that i see all the time
yes indeed conan matt gourley but not
sonam obsession
that's right sona as many of you know
just given birth to twin boys
uh mikey and charlie or mike and charlie
good stout armenian names and uh lovely
adorable adorable uh boys and so she's
taking time off i probably not pc of me
to say this but i think it's a betrayal
that she's uh
she's left the podcast
well it's flawed priorities in my
opinion one-month-old babies do fine on
their own podcasts need constant care
and attention uh but filling in uh for
for sona and those are mighty big shoes
to fill uh and and i mean that literally
she has someone has massive massive feet
size 18 is uh is david hopping
who is um this is how unimaginative we
are sona really is my assistant and then
taking over for sona is my assistant
david hopping so
something they probably don't mention
when you get a job with conan o'brien
that you may
have to be on a podcast when i started i
was basically sona's assistant yes
now listen sona is this what's spill the
tea
as people like to say uh sona um kind of
a wacky assistant as you know uh what is
it like working for her i mean that must
be quite strange oh it was great wait i
have a question she has an assistant
that's like renting an apartment to
someone and then they sublet it and just
make the money my technical title when i
started was conan's personal production
assistant but it was really direct like
reporting to sona right so basically and
i think i'm can follow up on matt's
question when sona got an assistant it
meant david was my assistant yeah
sona was watching her shows
right
she was watching her shows and you were
running around putting out fires left
and right uh i also watched a lot of
shows because she told me i could so she
what shows did she tell you you could
watch
any show oh so she encouraged you to be
a bad assistant well it was a few weeks
in and
i would come down every once in a while
just check in see if she needed anything
and finally one day she told me that i
could just sit at my desk and watch tv
till she called me that's incredible
what a gig yeah like i told you i did 14
seasons of grey's anatomy i did all of
gossip girl
uh most of shameless a lot of aero the
flash this is an unbelievable you were
getting a paycheck to watch television
while uh and and sona was telling you
that this was de rigueur this was she
said if anyone asked to say i was doing
research for you wow yeah because i need
my info on grey's anatomy you might
what did you interviewed ellen pompeo
season 55.
i saw in the paper yesterday in the
paper i'm sorry but i saw an article it
wasn't in the paper it was on some
screen that uh
i wanna you know what i do is i open up
my laptop and i use it to hide the fact
that i'm reading a newspaper
um
you have a three foot ipad yeah he
closes and opens it like he's opening a
new page yeah i have a giant giant uh
laptop with a massive screen that hides
the fact that i'm reading a 1950s
newspaper i'm like oh dewey defeats
truman a i uh i'm stunned by that i was
reading an article and it said that
grey's anatomy is coming back for
another season i thought that's still on
season 18. how do you know that it's
season 18 because i've watched 17
seasons because he works for you yeah
only 14 of them on your dime does
anybody do anything that works for me
jordan
who's there my associate producer i've
never found evidence that he does
anything and we've made it a bit on the
show and people think it's a bit and
it's not a bit we don't know what he
does sona never knew what she was doing
sonia used the corp card to buy us lunch
a lot so thanks for that's not supposed
to happen but we would get your lunch
too and then yeah and then i wouldn't
eat it both of us because i'd see myself
at uh
i'd see myself in the monitor at
rehearsal and say oh look at chunky
there chunky gets no lunch and you guys
would eat my lunch oh i would go get
your groceries every monday what
groceries you would get like turkey and
apples and like home grocers or for the
office like for the office i would go to
whole foods every monday mm-hmm so that
was one thing wow turkey's an apple the
conan o'brien oh i would take your tea
every day before the show i don't even
like tea everything you mentioned is
something i don't like what a wrestling
life you're living i know i'm talking
about an apple what are you in preschool
i'm sorry
i was trying to but i'm listening to it
now and it sounds pathetic you know it's
funny i don't like any of those things
what kind of juice box did you drink
yeah what was fun though is at whole
foods they don't have chopped red onion
but when i told them that it was for
conan they would take it into the back
and chop it that way sona and i wouldn't
have to and then spit on it
oh conan huh yeah we'll chop that up
real nice with my dick this is wet
jesus christ you get dick chopped onions
yes and i knew they were you haven't had
an onion until it's been dick chopped no
no no i'm sorry but it does have
it's just fantastic you are living a
rock star life i take it yes thank you
you take it all back yeah make sure that
onions dip chopped
the way they dick chop it in whole foods
who's dick chopping back there today is
it arthur i like the way arthur dick chu
arthur's gone what happened oh nasty
accident eh
no yeah dick shopping was off today well
i think we hammered that joke home
this is this is one of those moments
where i'm going to be walking somewhere
in los angeles and someone's going to
lean out of a window passing a car and
go
chopping
oh no next time you get a delivery of
onions from whole foods they're gonna
have a little tag on him that says dick
chopped by arthur
all right well i hope arthur's listening
yeah no trust me you better put some ice
on that thing